the big news in the news world because
the news loves talking about the news is
that Al Jazeera America launched this
week and they had a pretty fancy package
they put together to kick it off it is
really effective and in fact viewership
of Al Jazeera's growing up in the United
States because it's real news we will
connect the world to America and
Americans to the world what al Jazeera
has done is achieved something that all
of us I think want to achieve and that
is to make a contribution
in an era of consolidation al-jazeera is
expanding investing in a network of
bureaus across the United States
engaging our audience with real stories
about view people in the real world
alright that's some pretty fancy
packaging right there I mean I think
it's kind of hilarious that a news
organization based in Qatar has to be
the one thing that might save American
mainstream media kind of kind of
beautiful alright so there they promised
to do news they're gonna actually do
news not just drivel that we see on our
three cable news channels is it possible
they're gonna save television there I
think they're gonna try and they might
even give a really really good old
college try but I don't think people
will watch it because it's called
al-jazeera
I was in the public relations department
I'd be like how about fell Munira
anything that's not al-jazeera people
what is it though what is what people so
that uh here's a top of that I've heard
different things I've heard from people
that they do excellent reporting I don't
know I'm not familiar enough with them
but what what is it that al-jazeera or
what does it mean first of all was it
kind of most people are going to
associate it with the people who ran the
Osama bin Laden you put al in front of
anything and it's gonna Al Queda
yeah now I'm doing that truck for a boy
second now they showed it's not like
they put they didn't say hey Osama bin
Laden come down in the office we're
gonna do a shoot there they're just
provide they're providing his message
about is that al Qaeda was giving their
tapes to Al Jazeera in Qatar and we want
us to have seen those richer tapes
because Letterman the funniest thing in
the world he would do is those voices
the oh and one more thing he would do
happy birthday to Jane Fonda a mother
thing death to America
come on we wouldn't have had those yeah
I can see that but can alright so I yeah
I think why didn't they just call this
thing America today network or Al
Jazeera so I'm happy that have been
worked something about late
we're not algae's
but is it but also something as long as
Anderson Cooper isn't on it it's the
greatest thing in the world
cable news yeah and I'm looking for a
new option yeah I did I wasn't a big
current fan is that what you're we in
their office and say well yeah I don't
know what this place is anymore but you
can yeah III wasn't glued so I'm give
them a shot as what I say I'm not gonna
make it out of the studio alive well
there are there are armed security
guards at the door I'm I'm from Kansas
yeah I say this the great unwashed as I
am and they lie over spit States and all
that I just don't think that that
they're gonna get on board with
something called al Jazeera love it the
Midwest is gonna eat this up you kidding
me their graphics in Iowa and a P for
the world and that I was considered
basically a person of color in Kansas I
mean they it's not and I can say I
really feel like they're just not gonna
get on board to watch something called
al Jazeera hey everybody bring come back
from the cornfields early al jazeera's
doing and doing a special yeah close the
gap al Jazeera is doing yes did you guys
see this though one of the things
they're saying is they're gonna actually
only have six minutes of commercials
because they want per hour because they
want to give you more news now of course
what they're not telling you is that
it's just because they don't have a
advertiser free they should have a
classic rock station - yeah it's
commercial free what kind of a music
would they play a lot of that sound that
you made during this Farsi and the
cruisers come on people some of these
jokes have written themselves top Farsi
top Farsi station for you yeah all right
so so last thought on this is this just
so I'm you see what I'm tweeting all day
about cable news I mean is this just
that we actually whether this thing's
gonna be good or bad do we just need it
anyway as just a last chance to escape
the crap that we're all being any other
choice i watch the BBC world
occasionally I sit with a smoking jacket
and and also I just want to ask you one
thing who's booking this because I'm
working now Jazeera I am ready to go I
will attend the reporting I can put in a
call they're probably looking for a good
you